during my time a slender looking
white-haired boy is seen walking out of
a convenience store carrying his
groceries meanwhile a girl who looks
suspiciously like masaka Makoto is seen
on top of a rooftop the girls holding a
mounted sniper rifle positioned to fire
down the streets below she adjusts the
scope of the gun to accommodate the
change in the weather conditions the
target is the white-haired boy she
confirms the target's name accelerator
she fires the gun several times
seemingly accurate the bullet should hit
accelerator however a flash the bullet
returns to its Bearer destroying the gun
and hitting the girl she was severely
injured frantically she staggers to run
away apparently afraid of something
she runs into the alleys and sees the
object of her Terror there awaiting her
with a smile the white-haired boy that
should have been killed but still alive
it is daytime Tomah is walking to school
to attend his makeup classes Tomah stops
at a certain vending machine the pyramid
parts for a beverage Toma has no change
as such he uses a full 2000 Yen bill on
the machine he inserts the bill and
presses a button however no beverage
would come out he coerces the machine to
give him something but nothing would
come out because of this Toma utters a
familiar phrase his predicament is
interrupted by Makoto who pushes him out
of the way surprised at the arrival of
the young rude girl he asked to himself
who she is this irritates Makoto as
she's already told Toma her name before
he lost his memories
she fires an electric attack towards him
declaring her name and demanding him to
remember Toma however easily blocks the
attack with his right hand and confirms
to himself that she is actually an
acquaintance of his
in an instant Mikoto spins around and
kicked the vending machine on its side
exposing her shorts to Toma predictably
the machine spits out of Beverage Mikoto
then says that he can get the money back
to him and demonstrates this by sending
an electric current into the machine
however the machine instead spits out
several varieties of canned beverages
knowing what would happen Tomah runs
away while the vending machine alarm
sounds
Tomah rests on a bench when Makoto comes
up to him with the beverages she
pilfered from the vending machine
conversation is interrupted by the
appearance of Kuroko koroko introduces
herself to Toma and tells her that she
is mikoto's Herald and that Tomah should
check with her if he intends to hit on
the kodo this irritates Makoto so much
that she releases her electric powers on
Kuroko immediately after that Tomah
hears another girl he turns around to
see a girl who has the same face and
clothes as Mikoto she says that she's
Makoto's sister while describing on how
she says her sentence he asked the
sister why she is referring to herself
as masaka the sister tells Tomah that
her name is misaka without delay however
Makoto suddenly yells at her asking what
she is doing here
the misaka sister tells Makoto that she
is here for research and as such Makoto
calms down and asks her sister to come
with her for a while despite her
protests in the afternoon Tomah can be
seen carrying the various beverages Toma
soon realizes that Makoto's sister is
standing before him which he confirms as
she is wearing panties instead of shorts
Toma asks her on why she has with her
military goggles which she replies that
she needs it to track the flow of
electrons and magnetic forces unlike
Makoto Toma then asks her that wasn't
she dragged by mccomodo earlier to which
the sister denies and points to a
different direction to which she
originates they arrive at tomah's
dormitory building where they are
greeted by a maid on top of a spinning
cleaning robot Toma narrates that she is
Mika motoharu's stepsister
later Tomah meets mccobedo during the
afternoon here she is seen staring
towards The Horizon's seemingly deep in
thought Tom agreets her to which Makoto
acknowledges him with an unfazed
expression on her face Tomah walks on
and encounters Makoto's sister again
this time trying to feed a black cat
inside a cardboard box Toma takes the
cat with him Toma and the sister arrive
at a bookstore where Tomah wants to buy
a reference book for cats while
referring index and ASA suddenly a chill
runs down her spine and we see
accelerator behind her She lays down the
feline and faces him gunshots can be
heard in an Alleyway a sister falls down
due to a powerful force in the shadows
of the Alleyways runs mikoto's sister
she is breathing heavily while carrying
gun and wearing her goggles suddenly a
voice is heard speaking it is the voice
of Her Tormentor accelerator he asks her
why she is running and taunts her on how
she's flashing herself to him
because of his sister stops and fires
several bullets towards him seemingly
hitting accelerator
suddenly the bullets fly back towards
her and one of them hits her right
shoulder accelerator is still alive
unharmed he leans forward however the
girl fires her gun to his face strangely
the bullets stop in midair and has
redirected her thinking quickly she
Shields herself with her gun and throws
it towards him immediately after she
runs away putting a little distance
between her and accelerator she attacks
him with her electric powers however it
does not work in mikoto's sister gets
electrocuted by her own powers even in
pain she realizes what accelerator's
powers is reflection accelerator quickly
says that she is incorrect and that his
power is Vector change he enumerates a
list of things that he can control and
tells her that anything that has vectors
can be changed by him with a touch and
states that his power is set to reflect
by default
accelerator leans down and touches the
open wound of Makoto's sister
accelerator tells her that he is now
touching her blood and asks her
quizzically on what would happen to the
human body if the direction of the blood
flow is reversed he smiles widely and
tells her that if she answers correctly
she will be given a peaceful rest to her
horror meanwhile Tomah finally comes out
of the bookstore wondering where
mikoto's sister is while wondering where
she is Toma feels an eerie formoting in
a certain Alleyway Tomah investigates
the alleyway due to this feeling there
in the darkness he finds a lone bloody
shoe he keeps on walking under the color
of darkness and there in his sight lies
a girl he was looking for the girl who
was just talking to a while earlier that
girl was in her own pool of blood that
girl is Makoto's sister Toma is
completely horrified by what he has seen
he steps back a few times seemingly
unable to take in what has occurred
the scene cuts to several anti-skill
members guarding a certain location away
from bystanders we see Tomah sitting on
the ground in despair still with the cat
that he had left with a girl that has
now died
one of the anti-skill members approaches
him and asks if Tomah could come with
them to the scene of the crime Toma
obliges and escorts two anti-skill
members to the scene of the crime they
finally reach the supposed scene of the
crime but to Tom was bewilderment not a
drop of blood can be found confused as
to what happened he runs towards the
spot where he saw mikoto's sister lying
in her own blood however they find
nothing suddenly the cat notices
something Toma feels something off as
well and runs toward this feeling
leaving the empty skills behind
he traverses a considerable distance and
in the distance sees in the darkness The
Familiar glow of Makoto's sister's
goggles Tomah stops and looks at the
person before confirming that she is
truly alive who at the moment is
carrying a rather large bag big enough
to fit a person inside
Tomah is stunned and asks how it is
possible that she is still alive however
the sister corrects him stating that she
has truly died shocked by her statement
Toma asks what she is carrying the bag
the sister doesn't answer him but
demands Toma to decode a series of
letters and numbers seemingly password
Toma does not what is happening and as
such the sister tells him that Tomah is
not part of the experiment Toma tries to
figure out the contents of her bag
however he suddenly Hears A Familiar
voice from behind her she looks like
Makoto and the girl that is standing
before Tomah which surprises this girl
talks of sisters and another similar
looking girl talks on how she's
apologizing for leaving the cat behind
another one appears and says that the
reason for her actions is because she
did not want to involve an animal in
their conflict
another one appears apologizing for
worrying him
another one appears in another one the
Makoto sister that was carrying the bag
tells Tomah that every one of them is
muzaka she calls herself masaka 10032
and tells Tomah that she was the one
Tomah was interacting with all this time
she explains to Toma on how they use
their electric abilities to link their
similar brain waves together so they can
share their memories
coma asks who she is when she replies
that they are mass-produced clones for
military use that were created from the
DNA map of the third level five of
Academy City misaka Makoto she calls
themselves sisters Toma asks what they
are doing to which she replies that they
are simply doing an experiment though
she is not allowed to explain the
details of it
having finished their business the
Clones leave one by one with mizaka 10
000 and 32 asking Tomah to take care of
the cat for her
Toma is currently riding on a bus
heading for the tokawada Middle School
dormitory Tomah steps out of the bus and
heads into the tokawada middle school
dormitory Tomah discovers that Makoto
resides in room 208 and decides to use
the panel to contact her
the voice tells Tomah that she is her
onisama's roommate and not to worry
about bothering her she asks Tomo what
he wants with Mikoto and with Tomah
replying that it is not something major
the voice says that Makoto has not come
home yet but he is allowed to wait
inside their room Tomah comes in and
discovers that the voice belongs to the
girl she met earlier Kuroko koroka
allows Tomah to sit on her bed instead
of standing to which Toma asks what she
is doing on mikoto's bed and asks if
she's a pervert suddenly footsteps can
be heard from the hallway outside Tomah
thinks it's Mikoto however Kuroko know
who it is the tokuode dorm supervisor
koroko becomes worried of having her
find out that Tomah is inside their room
with no choice left koroko touches
tomah's shoulder and tries to teleport
him outside however she discovers that
her power does not work on him Toma
tries to explain that it is because of
his right hand which Kuroko grabs and
forces his body under Makoto's bed to
hide him while koroko go deal with the
supervisor
under the bed Tomah discovers documents
stuffed inside Makoto's giant stuffed
bear doll kurumer here he discovers that
the document he acquired contains
important information on the sisters
Toma reads that the tree diagram
calculated that only accelerator the
strongest level 5 of Academy City can
attain level 6 by preparing battlefields
and fighting according to scenario
accelerator's Grove into a level 6 will
be stimulated by the battlefield Toma
turns a page and discovers a map on it
discovering several crossout points on
it this is wrong Thomas said to himself
as he runs through the streets of
Academy cities his searching for one
girl alone masaka mikono as she is the
key to the madness that is occurring
with her sisters he sees that the
propellers of the wind turbines are
moving even though there are no winds
tonight
Tomah concludes that following the
turbines will lead to her to Mikoto a
level 5 electromaster who produces
electrical energy every second
on a bridge somewhere stands misaka
Makoto leaning on the railings looking
into the distance she asks herself why
things end up like this now
you see a flashback of a young Makoto
being odd on how she can produce
electricity the scene cuts to Makoto
inside a facility somewhere being asked
by a doctor if she was the famous masaka
Mikoto the young Makoto turns around as
if confirming her identity to him the
doctor continues by saying that there
are many handicapped people in pain who
can't even move their own limbs the
doctor tells her that if they have the
power to control the electricity within
their bodies they might be able to
provide those people with hope
the nurse that was with the doctor says
that they would be able to save a lot of
people if they were to apply her powers
on them a scene cuts to a group of girls
gossiping about a rumor about military
clones being produced in Academy City
where they're using a certain level
five's DNA as a base the gossip
continues until the girls see Makoto
where they then moved away though to
Makoto the rumors seemed ridiculous the
scene returns to the present we see
Makoto still leaning on the rails
occasionally emitting electricity
another flashback occurs several sisters
appearing before Makoto the scene Cuts
back to Makoto again where she mutters
help the scene Cuts again to several
sisters dead and lying on a pool of
blood and then to accelerate her smiling
suddenly a black cat walks into the
scene letting out a soft Mew sounds of
footsteps can be heard it is Tomas
Makoto is visibly surprised by his
arrival Tomah simply says to stop it to
which Makoto asked to stop what exactly
here Tomah cites his sentence from the
document he got out of Makoto's stuffed
bear regarding on how tree diagram
predicted the Ascension of accelerator
to level six by preparing 128
battlefields and killing Makoto 128
times however since it is impossible to
prepare 128 raildens Makoto Academy City
used the radio noise project that was
progressing in parallel as a substitute
for railgun by using 20 000 battlefields
and killing 20 000 clones of Makoto and
then the same results can be achieved
bikoto says to Toma that whatever that
he is suspecting is probably correct and
says that the marks on the maps look
like shot down marks of facilities that
she has taken down using her powers
Makoto continues that it was her plan
originally however no matter how many
facilities she had taken down other
facilities take up the project again
Mikoto continues by saying that the city
is always under surveillance by the tree
diagram which would imply that the
experiment is being allowed by the board
of directors as well
he states that since the centerpiece of
the experiment involves making
accelerators stronger than if he was
gone then obviously the experiment will
be halted Tomah says that she is lying
he says that she is not powerful enough
to defeat accelerator mccutter then says
that she'll be going to accelerator's
location now going to her death however
she is stopped by Tomah who stands in
front of her locking the path towards
her demise Lakota orders Toma to move
out of the way to which tomor replies a
single word no even the power of his
opponent Toma is Resolute and not
allowing Mikoto to pass through him
tonight mikono attacks once again and
this time Toma is engulfed in her power
making him fall
whilst Homa is on the ground after being
hit by Makoto's attack she becomes
regretful in attacking him however Tomah
stands out once more determined to not
let Mikoto pass him Dakota states that
she killed more than 10 000 people and
that there is no reason for a villain
like her to live in this world she asked
him why he is standing up for a Villain
Like Her however Tomah says that she is
not a villain filled with anguish Makoto
lets have her powers screaming the
attack was powerful enough to move
clouds and from afar the Bridge's tinted
blue as it is engulfed by her powers
only the sound of electricity can be
heard on the bridge in the middle of it
stands misaka Makoto who just released
one of her most powerful attacks on a
certain boy
suddenly she notices that he is moving
he is still alive much to her surprise
the boy Tomah struggles to stand up
while the obviously shocked Makoto moves
backwards she lets her hand out as if
she was going to attack
however this time Makoto is brought to
tears a young girl wearing the school
uniform is walking the streets of
Academy city alone during a wingless
evening
the scene cuts to a seemingly empty
Railway cargo holding area where we see
the girl walking into the area
she stops and starts reciting her
current coordinates as well as the time
the girl calls herself test material
10032 misaka 10032 she then recites on
how the purpose of the test is to
develop Maneuvers for battles where
reflection cannot be used accelerator's
reflection Tomah begins to regain his
Consciousness he looks at his hand and
recalls how he lost his Consciousness he
had taken mikoto's electric attack head
on without using his right hand he looks
around and sees no one on the bridge
suddenly tears drop from above is Makoto
weeping in with tomah's head resting on
her lap and with her being worried of
being hurt from her attacks Tomah speaks
and says that he now knows how to stop
the experiments he says that tree
diagram designed the experiment under
the assumption that accelerator is the
strongest esper in Academy City however
Tomo says what would happen if
accelerator was to be beaten in a street
fight he states that there is no reason
for the experiment to continue if the
Assumption of accelerator is the
strongest was false because of it says
that it's impossible as she draws from
her experience facing against
accelerator once that a battle with him
wouldn't even be called a match Mikoto
says that even if she was to
miraculously defeat the researchers will
simply conclude that it was within the
error range as such won't see
accelerator as weak Tomah stands up and
says that he will be the one to fight
accelerator as he's a level zero makota
protests saying that it is impossible
for him citing the fact that accelerator
can control all vectors and Toma being
heavily injured from Makoto's attack
however Como Simply Smiles in a smub
manner and shrugging of her protests and
asks her where accelerator's location is
the end be sure to subscribe for the
next epic part where our MC is facing
accelerator an epic fight